et de ce débat sur le pacs final on en
parle ce soir avec nos invités horno
benedetti rédacteur en chef de la revue
politique et parlementaire et frédéric
sinclair politologue et éditorialiste
pour valeurs actuelles
bonsoir messieurs merci d'être avec nous
ce soir sur arte france pour parler de
ce débat à l'assemblée nationale sur le
passé maximale alors on l'a vu un ce
matin avec cette suspension surprise de
l'examen du projet de loi ardo benedetti
est ce que cette suspension c'est aussi
le signe que la mise en passe en place
du pass vaccinale elle ne va peut-être
pas se passer comme l'exécutif l'avait
initialement prévu
c'est surtout le signe de la
désorganisation d'une majorité qui n'a
pas réussi à s'organiser mais
mathématiquement alors qu'elle dispose
d'une majorité absolue lorsque l'on
additionne les groupes de la république
a marché des groupes du modem sur un
texte qu'elle considère comme un texte
qui doit passer à marche forcée et en
urgence donc si le premier ministre doit
s'en prendre à des députés il doit son
propre d'abord aux députés de sa propre
majorité et non à ceux de l'opposition
qui en l'occurrence le finalement vu
lire c'est de bonne guerre ont fait
capoter en tout cas retarder le
déroulement et le déroulé de ceux de ce
texte je crois que c'est surtout ça
qu'il faut retenir de cette séance de
nuit or on voit bien aujourd'hui que la
stratégie de l'exécutif c'est de se
servir de cet échec parlementaires tout
à fait d'ailleurs momentanée parce que
le texte sera adopté alors peut-être pas
dans les délais que le gouvernement
souhaitait voir finalement respectée
mais ce qu'il faut retenir aujourd'hui
c'est que le gouvernement essaye de
faire de cet échec parlementaire un
levier pour une contre-offensive
vis-à-vis des oppositions on taxe en
loupe les oppositions d' irresponsable
au moment où il y à une recrudescence de
l'épidémie avec le vario micron enfin là
aussi c'est grossièrement politique s'il
lui dire monsieur castex dit que
l'opposition a fait un coup politique
ils essayent lui-même de faire un coup
politique ont des ans ont finalement ce
que l'opposition a fait c'est à dire
elle s'est opposée ce qui est naturel
dans une démocratie parlementaire et
frédéric saint clair à nos benedetti
parlais à l'instant d'échec un
parlementaire
justement est ce qu'il pourrait y avoir
est ce qu'on pourrait imaginer un impact
politique
après sept après cet événement
je ne crois pas je pense comme la comme
l'a dit implicitement arnaud benetti qu
on est presque dans l'anecdote le
le nombre de fois dans toutes les
législatures où la majorité s'est fait
coincer par ce qu'elles étaient en
minorité ce jour là et que les
oppositions en s'unissant ont réussi à
bloquer parfois plus que simplement une
prolongation de séance il peut arriver
qu'il ya des textes qu'ils soient
rachetées donc ça ça ça se produit assez
assez régulièrement en tout cas de façon
récurrente donc je vois mal comment il
pourrait sortir finalement des coups
politiques respectifs comme ça comme ça
vient d'être d'être dit la majorité
présidentielle sera présente au moment
des votes effectif et même s'il y a des
amendements comme vous l'avez souligné
dans votre reportage le le principe d'un
pass vaccinale sera adoptée peu ou prou
le 15 janvier un petit mot peut-être
pour revenir sur l'effectivité du coup
politique de christophe castaner qui
touche presque à l'indignité quand on
reproche les 272 morts du jour à un
ensemble de députés qui agissent de
façon simplement démocratique en dix ans
eric coquerel lundi à votre micro on ne
vote pas des textes importants entre
minuit et 3 heures du matin il semble
que c'est assez raisonnable comme
argument que ça peut être tentant dable
ce qu'on a vu c'est un premier ministre
qui perd ses nerfs simplement face à
l'hémicycle alors vous l'avez dit
frédéric saint clair peut-être aucun
aucun événement finalement sur sur la
tenue de ce pass vaccinale à à long
terme est ce que dans cette suspension
des débats cette nuit il faut t'y voir
peut-être un réel avertissement pour le
gouvernement et est ce qu'il doit d'agir
peut-être en conséquence arnaud
benedetti
à qui il faut voir surtout un
avertissement encore une fois sur une
majorité qui n'a pas été capable de se
mobiliser c'est à dire une majorité qui
n'a pas fonctionné de manière
professionnelle en l'occurrence ensuite
encore une fois moi je pense que ça
l'europe que très peu d'impact sur la
suite du débat parlementaire alors
maintenant reste à savoir si aujourd'hui
ça on va le voir sur la durée si les
mesures qui sont prises vont continuer à
être soutenus par l'opinion publique
jusqu'à preuve du contraire aller moi je
suis le premier surpris d'ailleurs en
l'occurrence ces mesures qui peuvent
être en effet contesté sur le plan du
droit sur le plan des libertés publiques
en raison notamment des discriminations
quand même qu'à des instituts au sein de
la société française entre deux
catégories de français ces mesures
jusqu'à présent ont été de profondément
soutenu par l'opinion publique ça c'est
une réalité en tout cas quand on regarde
les sondages mais est-ce qu'à terme
cette ce soutien de l'opinion publique
ne va pas finir par s'user ça c'est une
question qui convient de se poser est
est ce que cette usure finalement d'un
soutien de l'opinion publique va
intervenir dans le cadre de la campagne
électorale
il est clair que là en la matière ce
serait un très mauvais coup pour le
gouvernement à ce qu'on voit bien que
emmanuel macron et sa majorité font de
la crise sanitaire aujourd'hui un
bouclier protecteur de leur propre
majorité sur le plan politique parce que
quand même il faut en revenir à la
réalité des choses qu'est ce que c'est
aujourd'hui le vario micron c'est
invariant qui est certes est très
contagieux mais qui ne paraît pas si on
en croit en tout cas des médecins et les
scientifiques particulièrement dangereux
donc il y à dison il faut le clay est
clairement l'explicité une forme d'
usage politique qui fait de cette crise
sanitaire pour d'une certaine manière
les barres glacées la campagne
électorale est-ce que cela ça va durer
encore longtemps c'est une vraie
question il faut souhaiter en effet que
quand même on puisse desserrer l'étau
très rapidement pour que le
fonctionnement de la démocratie retrouve
un cours normal dans ce pays frédéric
sinclair je voyais approuvé un quand
arnaud benedetti parler de l'usure de
l'opinion c'est une vraie question ça
jusqu'à quand l'opinion va va justement
soutenir les mesures du gouvernement
c'est une question qu'on peut qu'on peut
se poser oui et c'est à mon avis c'est
presque la question centrale parce que
là le travail de l'exécutif et de la
majorité ne tient que sur ce soutien de
l'opinion aujourd'hui la les données
empiriques
progressivement compte est de plus en
plus là la validité des mesures qui sont
envisagés par le gouvernement
c'est à dire que en eau bénite il a
souligné les données scientifiques
montrent globalement un invariant qui
est
finalement si peu
l'étal que lorsque lorsque castex dit
que on est à 124 mille morts
aujourd'hui il oublie de préciser qu'on
était à cent mille morts en mars dernier
après une première année d'épidémie
c'est à dire que sur la deuxième année
et le variant delta qui nous tient en
haleine depuis le mois de juillet on a
simplement 24 mille morts de plus c'est
à dire un quart de ce qui s'est passé la
première année si on regarde les
chiffres sur au micron en afrique du sud
et ailleurs en europe ils sont
relativement faibles on comprend mal
aujourd'hui comment l'opinion peut
continuer d'adhérer donc la vraie
question c'est ce mouvement double de
sidération de l'opinion et d'hystérie za
sion de l'opinion qui est qui qui a qui
a tenu en haleine la france entière
pendant un an et demi à peu près est-ce
qu'il est va être capable de de se
poursuivre suffisamment longtemps pour
que l'exécutif puisse tirer emmanuel
macron particulier un bénéfice de 7,2
cette crise sanitaire et de ce pass
vaccinale parce qu'il me semble en un
mot et pour conclure que toute la
question aujourd'hui du pass vaccinale
voter le 15 janvier et là on a une vague
au micron qui est extrêmement violente
on a un premier tour de l'élection
présidentielle au 10 avril toute la
question posée par emmanuel macron c est
ce que mon pass vaccinale va être
implémenté à temps pour que je puisse
tirer un bénéfice politique de ceux de
ce pass vaccinale et dire face caméra
aux français regardez nous avons enrayer
l'épidémie au micron qui était
extrêmement massive grâce aux mesures
que nous avons prises et c'est parce que
nous avons prises à temps rapidement en
faisant peser la contrainte sur les non
vaccinés qui sont le nouvel ennemi dans
la population que tout a réussi et donc
ré incarner la figure du sauveur
utiliser justement cet argument à des
fins politiques pour la campagne
présidentielle c'est justement ça
peut-être arnaud benedetti qui pourrait
servir de bascule de l'opinion publique
on défaveur justement de du projet du
gouvernement
c'est à dire qu'à un moment donné si
vous voulez lusage grossier qui peut
être fait des circonstances épidémie que
peut se retourner
dans l'opinion publique il faut bien
comprendre aujourd'hui c'est que on est
capable beaucoup plus que par le passé
dans de larges segments d'opinion
publique de décrypter les mécanismes de
communication ou les mécanismes
propagandistes ce qui est aujourd'hui
quand même une réalité on est capable de
mieux comparer de mieux et valier il
n'en demeure pas moins que à ce stade
c'est vrai que jusqu'à preuve du
contraire emmanuel macron tactiquement
de ce point de vue là plutôt
indéniablement réussi à tenir la barre
et même à faire oublier les errements et
les dysfonctionnements multiples et
variés que la gestion de cette crise
sanitaire a suscité un moment donné aux
tout débuts dans l'opinion publique on a
complètement oublié l'épisode des
masques presque on a complètement oublié
l'épisode et est presque on a
complètement oublié que finalement la
cause matricielle aujourd'hui de la
situation dans laquelle on se retrouve
sur le plan épidémique scellier
finalement au désarmement des pitau que
l'on a continué d'ailleurs etc ont suivi
durant cette année puisque la calèche
supprimé 5000 y donc tout cela fait que
cette amnésie d'une certaine manière
collective sur laquelle paris emmanuel
macron a joué jusqu'à présent en faveur
d' emmanuel macron sauf que sauf que il
y à un hic aujourd'hui c'est que on
rentre dans une campagne présidentielle
et dans une campagne présidentielle il
ya des mécanismes un moment donné de
polarisation qui vont s'opérer qui vont
s'opérer progressivement durant le mois
de janvier durant le mois de février et
la positionnement tactique des manuels
macron va être de plus en plus difficile
à tenir un autre point sur lequel il
faudrait quand même assisté c'est que il
ya un certain nombre d'arguments tout à
fait rationnel qui à part est inaudible
aujourd'hui c'est à dire dire que par
exemple un certain nombre de maladies
comme les avancées ou les cancers qu
plus tous les jours c'est à dire 800
personnes par heure par jour qui
décèdent sur d'un avc soir d'un cancer
que le conte vite ce sont des arguments
qui apparaissent inaudible pour
l'instant peut-être le deviendront-ils
si un certain nombre de candidats qui
sont considérés condé candidat légitime
je pense notamment aux candidats
républicains quoi que tous les candidats
soient légitimes mais en plus qu'à des
candidats plus compétitifs arrive à
porter je lire ce type d'arguments dans
débat public et surtout et le courage de
les porter peut-être qu'à ce moment là
l'opinion publique aussi bougera merci
beaucoup arnaud benedit d'avoir été avec
nous ce soir merci également à vous
frédéric saint clair merci à tous les
deux pour ce débat sur arte france merci
beaucoup